- There’s not a game—there’s not a game I played in that I wasn’t high.
♪♪♪
- There it is.
Yes!
[Laughing]
♪♪♪
- A lot of people remember the day
when you got traded from the Vikings to the Seahawks.
When you got to Seattle, like, once you finally got there and got with the team,
what was that experience like?
- Oooh, man. Um, if I could, if I could, uh, put it to you, just as layman’s I could,
those was probably the, the worst years of my life.
Just cuz it came with so much.
My anxiety is at its worst when I go into unfamiliar situations.
- When did you realize that you had an anxiety disorder?
- When I was diagnosed, I still didn’t acknowledge it.
But when I started noticing it is when I started speaking or going into
different environments, um, particularly the, um,
the press conference with the Seahawks.
My shirt was sweatin’. Uh,
they had to bring me water a couple times during my press conference.
- What do you recall as the worst instance of you acting out as a result of anxiety?
- My worst one, I would say, you know, the, the Super Bowl incident.
- Was it Golden Tate?
- Mmhmm.
- [Master Tesfatsion:] Take me through that. Who were y’all playin’,
what was going on throughout
Super Bowl week, and what was the end result of that?
- Thinkin’ about it now, man, I, I can’t even believe I did it.
So, we’re down at the Super Bowl, of course, the year in, uh, New York.
Um, we were playin’ the, um, Denver Broncos, uh, Peyton Manning.
We’re at the practice facility—we had to practice inside cuz it was cold, snowin’.
And, um, Golden did an interview, and I had just sat out the previous game,
um, with a concussion.
So, the, the question's “How do you feel, you know, gettin’ Percy Harvin back
and, you know, gettin’ some of y’all power back?
You know, gettin’ ready to play this, you know, tough Denver Broncos team.”
And the, the response was, “We made it here without him so, you know,
whether he play or don’t play, you know, we, we gonna be good.”
- So how’d you respond to that?
- [Percy Harvin:] Fast forward to we’re in the meeting room,
and I kinda asked him about it.
Like, “Yo, bro.” Like, you know, “What’s, what’s goin’ on?”
Like, “You, you ain’t even happy for me? Like, this had been goin’ on all season.”
I was so already wrapped up it didn’t even probably matter what his answer was.
Anything he coulda said,
I still was goin’ “Whatchu”—you know, I was, I was already at 10.
So...him addin’ 10.5 or whatever else, I was already there.
- [Master:] I have some sources in the Seahawks locker room
that witnessed that, and they said you punched him into a laundry hamper?
Did that actually happen?
- [Percy:] Let’s just say we, we got, we, we, we, we, we locked up.
Um, you know, the owners had to come in, in the locker room,
and the fact though—the hittin’ him into the trash can
and, uh, all that type stuff—it, it, it, it was true.
Um, like I said, man, it was, it was just bad.
The whole situation that—what you,
what we keep harpin’ on, that’s what made it bad.
Cuz it was team pictures that day, and you see, can see “tense” in the picture.
You don’t see, like, a, a team ready to play the Super Bowl.
- You gave him a black eye five minutes before the team photo.
What happened next?
- [Percy:] Uh, Beast Mode was the peacemaker, and, uh, he was kinda
just like, “Yo, Pete wants you to do this and that.”
Like, “Let’s just do this, man, so we can move on. You know, let’s just move on.” So.
And actually, that came the day of the game.
We kinda gave dap literally while we warmin’ up, kick returners out and all that.
And we kinda just like, “Man, it’s the Super Bowl, man. It’s all good, man.”
And we hashed it out that way.
I never really had done this before, but to finally tell, you know,
my man Dougie and, uh, Golden that them situations,
they were on your boy, 100 percent.
- [Master:] What was your solution to kinda
help cope with these anxiety situations that popped up?
- Now you’re lookin’ at a guy that—I was at the Mayo Clinic
and I had at least seven prescriptions that I was
to take, from Zoloft and all the other ones I was takin’.
And the only thing that really seemed to work is when I would smoke marijuana.
- How often did you smoke, Percy?
- There’s not a game—there’s not a game I played in that I wasn’t high.
And that’s what I want the world to kinda see today is
it’s not a stigma and, you know, people doin’ it and
gettin’ in a whole bunch of trouble.
It’s people that’s just livin’ regular life
that just got deficiencies or just maybe wanna enjoy themselves.
Um, it’s a natural way to do so.
- How crazy is that—that y’all still won the Super Bowl despite all this chaos?
Am I wrong?
[Laughing]
- Thanks for kickin' it with us.
Subscribe to B/R to check out more dope videos like this one.